hey David it seems as though it is red
states rather than blue states opening
early from coronavirus and Republicans
rather than Democrats who ignore social
distancing and mask-wearing is it
possible that coronavirus could hand the
election to Biden by killing more
Republicans than Democrats okay I
understand the argument I understand the
argument if you've got a state like
Michigan for example we'll just pick
Michigan and the Democratic voters are
mostly following the guidelines and the
Republican voters are not aren't you
going to get more Republican voters
infected with the virus and thus more
Republican voters will die and it could
flip Michigan from Trump in 2016 to
Biden in 2020 so first of all disclaimer
I hope it's not necessary I don't want
anybody to die I'm not hoping anyone
dies Democrats Republicans it's a
question about math really not a
question about anything else I don't
believe the deaths are numerous nearly
numerous at this point for this to
actually affect the outcome in any state
let's look at an example I mentioned
Michigan in 2016 Trump won Michigan by
about 11,000 votes right now Michigan
has had 5,500 coronavirus deaths even if
we imagine which I'm sure is not the
case imagine that a full 80% of the
people who died in Michigan are Trump
voters it's still not enough to flip an
11,000 vote margin and that's a state
where the margin was really really small
now
if Michigan ends up with 50,000 deaths
and 80 or 85% of them were Trumpets
you might have enough to flip the state
from Trump to Biden the reality is it's
unlikely Michigan is going to get 10x
the deaths we've seen so far by election
day and I think the most important thing
here and again I don't want anybody to
die no one else has to die for us to
realize Trump failed us on coronavirus
in other words if you believe that
coronavirus will affect how people vote
you shouldn't need any more deaths you
shouldn't need anybody else to die from
the virus either for political or
mathematical reasons as we're talking
about for us to know Trump's biggest
test so far has been coronavirus and
he's failed he's being tested on
civil unrest he's also failing there we
shouldn't need anyone else to die to be
able to say he failed us and he needs to
go last thing on this coronavirus is
also disproportionately affecting poor
people and communities of color those
are communities that disproportionately
vote for Democrats over Republicans so
the older folks the which is a group
that has been better for Trump and for
Republicans they're of course the most
at risk from an age perspective but you
also have communities of color and poor
communities that are disproportionately
affected those are not communities that
are likely to go to trump so I would
even challenge the assertion that that
we started with which is that it is
simply going to be split primarily among
party lines based on following or not
following social distancing guidelines
in the end 130 million people voted in
2016 just to affect 1% of the electorate
you need 1.3 million coronavirus deaths
we are nowhere close to that I hope we
are never anywhere close to that and
certainly there's no indication we would
be anywhere near that in November so it
is unlikely unlikely that the who dies
from coronavirus would be enough to flip
even a single state even a state that
was really close in 2016 by enough votes
to change the outcome if you disagree
with me let me know we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at join pakman.com or by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show